crime and police think multis is with us
now good morning to you thanks for
joining us on the program
care pleasure and thanks for covering my
sobriety story yesterday these ankle
bracelets are going to make a huge
difference to alcohol-related crime we
think
glad to hear it come in and talk to
about it in more detail whenever you'd
like to but
for this morning let's talk about uh the
tiering system
um it does look as though it's proving
quite divisive
obviously we're in a very tricky
situation uh right where
this virus is is moving at different
speeds in different parts of the country
and so we're having to have a different
approach
that's naturally creating tension um but
what we hope is that the vast majority
of people
recognize that we have a an individual
duty to our collective health
they inform themselves about what the
regulations are in their area and they
comply and happily we're seeing that now
there will always be you know as i say
tensions particularly between political
leaders
who are each trying to do the right
thing as they see it for their area for
the country but it looks like in the
vast majority of the areas where we are
seeing
um you know tougher um lockdowns if you
like we're we're getting cooperation
from both sides and reaching a good
settlement most deprived areas are
suffering most so aren't they that's why
they need more money
well it's tough everywhere right i mean
everybody's having quite a hard time at
the moment and we recognize the burden
that's placing on all sorts of areas and
that's why the government is doing its
best
to try and support as many businesses
and individuals as we possibly can reach
accommodation with local leaders
so there's a sort of cooperative
approach to this thing certainly below
the sort of political level
you know the the public sector from
local authorities to police to health to
other partners are now in good shape
you know all those local resilients uh
four are working well together
this you know the um strategic
coordination groups across the country
also
coordinating well so i think from a
structural point of view we're in good
shape but look it's a pandemic
it was never going to be easy um talk to
us if you would please
i i i heard the prime minister at prime
minister's questions yesterday i'm not
sure i was completely clear after you've
made the point
what does the region have to do to come
out of tier three does it does the
does the r number need to be below one
so the r number needs to drop but i
don't need to be below one well it needs
to be low enough that we we're not going
to see a significant spread but there
are a number of other things that's
below one though well yeah in theory
it's below one
um but it also it relates the infection
rate in the in the community as a whole
but also other indicators right what is
the capacity in the local
hospital are we able to cope with any
kind of rise in that particular area
there will be a conversation
every 28 days with local leaders and
obviously with the health boffins who
are looking at the numbers
to look at whether we can get people
areas out of tier three i mean look
nobody wants to
to impose these things it's a pain for
everybody and it's really tough and it's
having a huge impact on young people
the economy everything so we want to get
out of it as quickly as we possibly can
but we have to be measured about doing
that and make sure we stay on top of the
virus remembering
that you know our primary goal here is
to get through this in reasonable shape
maintaining capacity in the nhs so they
can deal with covid
and with all the other health related
problems at the same time maintaining
schools
keeping businesses open so we limit the
damage that this thing is going to cause
but does it need to be below one they
are right
it depends on the overall picture in the
area
to be honest with you okay i'm not
sitting around the table making those
assessments
ideally if we can get the r rate down
below one that's where we want to be
nationally
and locally yes okay um yesterday robert
jenner was sat there
um he said he didn't know what the rules
were on jim's in greater manchester
then yesterday i think two police
officers were speaking to a select
committee
and they were saying that the new tier
three system was too confusing you're
the policing minister is it
uh well look the first thing to say is
there's plenty of information
out there there's plenty of places that
you can go and find out what the rules
in your area
that are there are some basic rules that
everybody needs to bear in mind
obviously rule of six
hands face space all that kind of stuff
but the key thing i think is about
social interaction
right in all circumstances we're saying
that if you you know from
an education point of view you can
gather from a work point of view if you
really need to
uh you can gather but from a social
point of view
you know in in the lower tier in the
medium tier you know
you can gather rule of six indoors and
outdoors for tiers two and three you
can't gather indoors and for tier threes
you can't gather outdoors
in private space although in public
space you can um if you maintain rule of
six but look i'm already confused well
what basically we need people to be
sensible right everybody understands
social distancing
everybody hopefully understands the rule
of six um and
in local areas there are some variations
about what can be open and what can't
and i think it's beholds all of us to go
and inform ourselves
about what conditions we're living under
and make sure that we comply can jim's
open in manchester
so i don't think jim's can um i'm not
entirely sure but then i don't live in
manchester
if i were a gym user in manchester i
would go and check on the regulations
when were your last gym users so i am a
pure gym i am a pure gym member and
until
i don't know a few months ago i was in
the gym in the morning
yep look i might not you might you know
it's always a struggle these things to
stay fit particularly given my
uh lifestyle but i i'm a gym member i
think i'm still paying my
my gym membership as it happens some
might say you need a refund
oh well i i've got to work as i say it's
a constant battle okay
apparently well i'm not sure either but
i just kind of you too
to inquire after my health yes i think
gyms are allowed to be open in
liverpool and also in lancashire i'm
guessing they will be in manchester as
well
it's look people have to go and check so
it is confusing yeah well it's not
confusing if you go and check
right and fundamentally that's what we
need people to do well i can't know from
every particular area i know the basics
and i understand but these things are
moving very quickly the thing to bear in
mind
okay is the one thing we know about this
virus is that it moves very rapidly
right it grows exponentially and it
recedes very quickly
and so we're having to be agile and that
means that everybody needs to be aware
in their area
of what the regulations are and it there
are lots of places that they can go and
inform themselves
and they may change you know we're going
to be reviewing them every 14 28 days
but to stay on top of the virus we all
have to be alert and that means being
alert to the regulations
um talk to me about what rishi sunax is
going to say today i don't know i mean
we're all a bit excited about what the
chancellor's going to say
today but um as we've seen throughout
the
pandemic the chancellor has come to the
house of commons and made announcements
to show how he's responding to the
or flexing if you like the support
that's required in the economy
to make sure that we stay in as best
shape as we possibly can but i haven't
had sight of what he's going to say are
we going to pay for it all i mean it's
the highest debt since 1916 we were
still paying off
what we owed for the second world war
then well that is going to be the big
challenge
and that is to be honest with you you
know he's got one of the toughest jobs
in the country at the moment is
balancing
the support that we put into the economy
the billions frankly that we're having
to spend to get
people through this in reasonable shape
um against what the
downstream cost is going to be now you
know back in 2015 i well remember um
george osborne announcing the house of
commons the day on which we finally paid
off the national debt from the first
world remember yeah and that took us a
hundred years
um and whether your taxes up can you
because you're part of your manifesto
said that you're not going to put up bat
national insurance
or income tax well you'll have to ask
the chancellor about what the
the overall cocktail of finances is
again as a conservative you wouldn't
want to well i you know
we need to bear in mind the health of
the economy and all taxation has an
economic effect
um and i know that the chancellor will
be thinking about that as he puts his
package together now obviously
you know announcement was made yesterday
that the spending review now is only
going to be a year
the budget has been delayed a little bit
and that's because our manifesto didn't
include the pandemic
and we have to respond to those things
your responsible government
looks at the situation it's faced with
and then addresses it accordingly and
i've no doubt
that i put in place a good balanced
package that will do
the best we possibly can to get the
country back on its feet what on earth
is going on with brexit talks we were
told
that we needed to get ready for a no
deal now it looks as though talks are
happening again how are businesses
supposed to prepare
for something that's going to happen in
just a few weeks time if they don't know
whether there's going to be a deal or
not
well as in all uh aspects of business
and you know i've been in business for
20 odd years now you prepare for the
worst and hope for the best
um and it does look like we've had a bit
of movement over the last couple of days
from our partners in the eu
negotiations are starting again that is
a cause for hope
but at the same time we're getting quite
close to the deadline and so
you know the government has said to
businesses um privately and publicly
that they need to prepare
for the possibility that we might go out
on on wto terms
and put themselves in in a good position
for that now we've done as much as we
possibly can to prepare for that
we did it last time we've dusted that
off and supercharged at this time
and so i think from a governmental point
of view we're in good shape and we're
encouraging businesses
to do um exactly the same but look
fingers crossed that this new
intensification of talks results
in you know sensible heads all round and
we get the result that we want
great at negotiating though are you i
mean look what happened with greater
manchester
well i i mean i think we got a result in
greater manchester in the end didn't we
uh we finally got there yeah look this
is a negotiation
right negotiations are you imposed well
negotiations often involve a bit of
temper and tension and slamming doors
and walking out and all that kind of
stuff it's in the nature of a
negotiation
that these things become tense
particularly towards the end when you're
facing a deadline
it's naturally a human situation
the point is do we get to the end with a
good resolution and on manchester we did
and let's hope we do on the eu as well
why did you vote against the motion to
extend free school meals for kids
so this is a really tough one uh kay and
it has been you know a challenge for all
mps
over the last few months not least
because our email inbox has been filled
with stories of difficulty and hardship
from our constituents
and having to make these kinds of
decisions is really hard fundamentally
you know we took a decision early on the
best way to help those on low income
was to pump money into the welfare
system and so nine billion pounds has
gone into that system
to assist people on on lower incomes you
know universal credit now up by a
thousand pounds
a year you know we've changed the
housing benefit rules to enhance
people's ability to pay their rent
there's council tax support there's lots
of resource that's gone in to make sure
that we target help
to those on on low income why are you
being told as mps by the conservative
whips to
gang up against marcus rashford i
haven't been told to gang up
okay so the the whips have um issued a
statement and one suggest that
with suggested interventions and a memo
two mps one suggested intervention
when labour in government they refuse to
extend preschool meals into holidays
these sort of comments should be put
onto twitter if marcus rashford talks
about kids
not getting free school meals this is a
footballer who wants to put
food in kids bellies taking on the
government
and you're ganging up on him i mean
that's pathetic well i don't
think it's necessarily ganging up i mean
it's standard practice during any debate
um for political parties to issue briefs
with suggested
lines well i don't think it's
necessarily against footballers right
but
quite a lot of this debate takes place
on twitter now so i don't think it's
particularly
um remarkable do you think it's
appropriate well
look mps have to make their own
decisions i didn't see that mps have to
make their own decisions about what they
say publicly
and parties obviously give guidance and
information about what the party
position is in a particular circumstance
it doesn't strike me as surprising but
look you know i nobody is
is decrying what marcus rashford is
trying to do yeah and it's coming from a
good fight
and he's come from a you know i suppose
a humble background
he's had that experience he's now a very
successful young man he wants the same
for everybody else
and i think what frustrates people is
this assumption that we don't
whereas in fact we do you know i've
spent 20 odd years in public policy
in inner city london and now in
hampshire i've dedicated
enormous amounts of my life to trying to
to better
the progress of my fellow citizens and
the problem with these situations is
where you get these really tough
decisions which governments naturally
have to take and that's the
you know the privilege and indeed the
difficulty being government that somehow
our motives are impugned
we think that we you know the best way
to help people on low income
is to give them great schools great jobs
uh yeah universal credit which has been
decried months ago and
we talked about why are you taking on a
footballer on twitter
well you'd have to ask the the whips
office to come on and explain that and i
don't think they're necessarily taking
him on
i think what we're trying to do is try
to take him down no we're not we're
trying to put our point forward to say
that we think there is a
better smarter way notwithstanding the
very good motivation that he has
for his career better way to target the
money no i understand
and the wips office is saying this is
how you take him down
well as i say we think the best way uh
to get this
money to people on low income is through
the welfare system which we've you know
in the teeth of a gale of opposition
built a fantastic system which has
performed incredibly well
uh during the this crisis and is now
funneling money
to the lowest paid um as in you know to
a much greater degree than it was before
okay we're out of time but you're here
to talk about uh barring eu criminals
tell me quickly
yeah so um we have for some time been
able to
uh bar those convicted of a crime and
sentenced to over 12 months
from overseas from non-eu from entering
the country we're now extending that
rule to eu nationals as well
and also saying that we will take a look
at your offending history even if you
haven't been convicted
um for a sense of over 12 months
to make sure that we take control of our
border and that we know who's coming in
and out we do see
sadly um uh often organized uh criminals
from the eu and indeed the rest of the
world
coming in uh to perpetrate their crimes
in the uk and this gives us much greater
ability to
to bar them from coming in in the first
place yeah but we won't have access to
the europol database will we
well you know so we're working closely
with with eu partners to have
workarounds around those particular
issues and you know
security has its own imperative and
we're pretty confident that whatever
basis we leave the eu
you know that the the security forces
and the police across the eu will work
together and don't forget we have
interpol as well that sits above europol
but fingers crossed k this new movement
results in
in a in a good deal for our exam for the
eu what gym work do you do
so i do uh two things broadly i spend a
lot of time on the cross trainer
um because it means i can watch you yeah
first thing in the world very good
um on the box and then occasionally have
a go at the rowing machine for five
minutes for a fall off
excellent thanks for joining us we
appreciate it